the cop car was because of a sex thing
we're getting so dark mrs. Busbee this
is for families hi my name is Anita
procedure and I'm Ross dress balem and
I'm pickle I think that's a lot I don't
know about these two I think there's
some like dark corridors of secrets that
I'm about to find out I feel like I know
a lot but this is fun too
I think I already know too much I'm
excited to see what secrets I'm gonna
use again I mean like amazing I have fun
[Music]
with family it was Easter Easter and
Easter gathering I came home and drag
just to get footage of my dad and I like
loving one another for an audition I was
like look my family loves me cut okay
I'm leaving that's a very specific
experience that really fits questions
really does anyone win this game okay
Devine sex
why don't you define sex since the
answer is obviously yeah okay so I've
never like had sex sex but I have gone
down on someone in a club bathroom while
looking like a 90s prostitute no way we
know who you know you don't yeah we do
don't make me say that name wait we do I
don't know you don't I do
oh you hesitated well maybe it was
somebody who had to happen multiple
times well moving on next question oh no
I don't know guys what do you think um
yeah
why don't you think I've gotten done
cheak she I don't know whatever it was
it might be like Botox wait what yeah I
was gonna say whatever you got it wasn't
enough confidently dragger don't fall it
happens all the time I don't know how
can he'll skip that part of the drag
seminar and so now I don't know how to
do how to walk in heels so I follow the
time I was like having a moment and I
just went I started the verse I come
walking down the stairs and I [ __ ] in
a gown looking gorgeous lip-synching
already to a pop song and I was just
like done own it though oh I did I got
right the [ __ ] back up and got that lip
sync on point what do you think we're
doing after later yeah how do you think
we met where do you like draw that line
like if they're participating or they're
just watching the camera yeah yes for
something yes keep going 3 4 5
definitely that I can recall Susie I
think that like I could have done
without two of them I would have made
sometimes the casting process was a
little loose so cute it was like I'm not
going to be petty about this are you
kidding me oh well not intentionally but
yes because things end up in your bag
and then you're like this guy's product
I guess I'll have to keep it as account
of stealing if you like take something
from them without them knowing and then
use it in your wardrobe that's what
stealing is so just I didn't get it now
I haven't really attempt you have an
intentional no you end up with things
though and then you intentionally don't
give it back I feel like we all grew
together as a group what are you
actually
did I win
[Music]